querer ser siembra rosas en este huerto
desde hace 35 años
pero ha decidido cambiarse de rubro
le apostará el cannabis para uso
medicinal las hectáreas que se van a
migrar a cannabis con hectáreas nuevas
de rosas no no tengo ninguna interna
deja las rosas pero si creo que esta es
una industria con un potencial enorme y
las ventajas que tiene ecuador como país
tiene ventajas que ningún otro país del
mundo las tiene las rosas son el
principal producto de exportación en
ecuador sin embargo con la reforma del
código orgánico integral penal se ha
abierto una nueva línea de negocios a
los productores y trabajo para la mano
de obra pero aún hay barreras por
derribar al principio los estigmas que
decían que no que debería retirarme
porque había supuestamente que era la
planta la de decían que era mal la que
nos servía que no se montón estigmas que
le decía pero con el tiempo fuimos
viendo que no era cierto
laboratorios y ecuatorianos ya están
preparando medicamentos con cannabis
películas con epilepsia agradece que ya
esté disponible esa opción medicinal en
su país que yo me caigo me quedo en un
piso y después como que reaccionó
con un poco del dolor de cabeza y
entonces no me he dado cuenta de eso
pero ahora con las gotitas he podido
controlarlo mucho mejor
no puedo ya no me da en la mañana nada
en la noche pocas veces esto de aquí se
vende así klaus además de rosas ahora
vende sus recetas de cannabis y que el
mercado por ahora se mantendrá con los
dos rubros a la espera de resultados
económicos para ver si se concentra sólo
en este nuevo negocio